bonjour chantal maignan bonjour maurice
violland bonjour aux auditeurs qui nous
font la main qui y est nous écouter ce
matin présidente du parti régionaliste
martiniquais candidate de la république
en marche c'était dans le centre
atlantique le week-end dernier
chantal maignan pour ce scrutin que nous
vivons jamais un appel au vote le vôtre
pour philippe edmond-mariette n'aura
fait autant couler d'encre on va le
préciser vous membres de pmm qui
appelait à voter contre une autre
candidate estampillée 1 pmn en
l'occurrence josette manin
d'abord je vais féliciter jean marc
parti pour son édito ça m'a beaucoup
amusé et en effet je pense que dans ce
gr grand canal ou peut-être ce grand
migan les choses devraient être
clarifiés après ces élections
législatives car il me semble qu'on
oublie que nous sommes précisément à des
élections législatives etc on ressort
les vieilles bannière des coalitions de
décembre 2015
ça fait deux ans qu'ils avaient servi à
mettre la martinique à feu et à sang
contre deux blocs défini depuis le temps
a passé
l'eau a coulé sous les ponts est ce que
ces coalitions en a une qui a la
responsabilité à la martinique et je
vois qu'elle a été récusé roule a
demandé de s'occuper du pays c'est pas
bien j'en suis très contente il s'agit
du grand ensemble et je compte bien
semble probable en soit là et c'est très
bien c'est très bien parce que je pense
qu'il ya des responsabilités assumées au
niveau du pays il faut remettre la
martinique en mouvement et puis l'autre
coalition pour moi ne pas exister parce
qu'elle n'a pas fonctionné c'est pas
parce que quelqu'un brandi l'étiquette
pmn que ça veut dire que je partage pour
les élections nationales ont craché dans
la soupe chantal mino se nourrissent pas
je respecte je respecte mais je dis que
pour les élections présidentielles sadi
nationale présidentielle et législatives
nous avions déjà dit que nous gardions à
la fois notre intégrité en termes de
positionnement politique et notre
indépendance
donc je vous êtes manet a été très clair
très franche et l'a clairement dit
qu'elle se positionnait contre le manuel
macron et qu'elle siégerait dans
l'opposition donc pour moi la question
est tranchée
vous qui avez su prendre à choisy
emmanuel macron emballage alors comment
expliquer ce matin chantal bignan que on
assure vous cette impression de côté
madame tall a dit exactement mais c'est
normal vous savez quelle est ta main
politique
elles sont toujours très regardée
peut-être que moi je représente beaucoup
parce que je suis très surprise avait de
l'intérêt commun porteur j'imagine qu'un
effet or au belge un certain nombre de
personnes qui m'apprécient et qu'ils
écoutent ce que je dis
eq un domaine très bonne opinion ça doit
être pour ça mais c'est pas vrai parce
que depuis le départ j'ai été à l'ump
comme vous le savez j'ai quitté l'ump
pour créer le parti régionaliste
martiniquais et je n'ai pas varié parce
que même dans au pmn j'ai gardé la loi
ça n'a jamais varié reprises sur
l'échiquier politique martiniquais
peut-être que je ne fais pas assez de
pédagogie peut-être que je devrais en
faire davantage mais je le ferai je
crois que je n'ai jamais varié et que
même dans le pmn je suis resté une
progressiste de droite
vous savez on aime bien assimilé les
gens à ont valu aux parties qu'il faut
le plus de bruit je me rappelle qu'à
l'époque de au pmn on voulait absolument
dire que j'ai fait passer au ppm ce qui
n'a jamais été le cas et aujourd'hui je
peux j'apporte encore une fois la preuve
à la fois de mon indépendance de mon
courage politique
non je ne voterai pas pro madame manet
parce qu'elle est enceinte on parle de
l'opportunisme de chanson mignon non
mais on peut en parler puisque j'ai
entendu beaucoup d'hommes du camp
politique l'opportunisme mais une
qualité et il n'a pas été critiqué pour
cela maintenant ça vous a pas échappé
que nous sommes en plein dans les
périodes dans ces épreuves du bac 2010
est on a connu la philosophie hier et
parmi les sujets suffit-il d'observer
pour connaître quand vous observez vous
avez rappelé votre parcours de la droite
dure façon certes résiste partie de
journée ce martiniquais pour grossistes
gaulliste aujourd'hui avec en marche
reconnaissait que vous vous observez ce
n'est pas si simple chantal mignon à 6
pour ceux qui s'intéressent à la
politique je parle de ce qu'est une
culture politique ceux qui s'intéressent
à l'histoire de la politique mon
parcours est limpide
je n'ai pas varié d'un iota je suis
gaulliste et je reste une femme de
droite
maintenant j'ai toujours été un
progressiste et je vais dans un parti
qui en même temps propose le
développement économique mais leur
respect aussi d'une politique sociale
fraternelle et solidaire
nous venons d'une histoire douloureuse
nous sommes des nains grand donc lé
clair que pour nous la droite française
de la gauche française n'ont pas le même
le même retentissement et le même
rapport nous devons créer notre
appartenance ont devant ajouté nos
spécificités dans ce qui nous est
proposé par l'échiquier national et
c'est pour ça que j'ai beaucoup apprécié
l'initiative d'emmanuel mâcon
concilier ces étiquettes parce qu'au
delà des étiquettes il ya des personnes
il y a des convictions il ya des
espérances aussi pour le pays et c'est
pour ça je suis j'ai adhéré à en marche
avec beaucoup d enthousiasme
en tout cas les échanges sur les réseaux
sociaux il ya vos échanges avoue ceux de
vos adversaires qui amène quand même
quelques ce qui est quelques questions
vous avez écrit notamment que si le pmn
était une secte dirigée par la baguette
du ppm vous en sortez alors dites-nous
ce matin le prm avec le pmn chantal
maignan
le président du prm au sein de pme c'est
définitivement terminé
cela ne fonctionne pas comme ça et même
le ppm n'a pas vocation à exclure
quiconque
nous sommes onze parties pour que nous
puissions prendre une décision
collective il faut réunir les 11 parties
je pense qu'après les élections
législatives il faudrait faire leurs
affaires sur les explications et des
décisions et je crois que ça a trop
tardé
la preuve c'est que regarder sur le nord
aujourd'hui je sais pas s'il va d'une
élection législative dans des conditions
très particulières parce qu'en face de
lui il y ades d'eurazeo est qui est sa
suppléante
une patronne du balisiers de saint
joseph et qui sont son président du
comité de soutien
le ppm du carbet vous voyez bien que les
choses ne sont pas très claires et que
par conséquent il faudra mettre toutes
les capsules thibout sonné la charge
contre le pp je ne sommes pas la charge
jeudi que le moment des explications est
sans doute arrivé qu'après les élections
déclare serge jammy dessus quel est
selon vous mais ce n'est pas mon
problème aujourd'hui moi mon problème
aujourd'hui c'est de venir dire à ma
circonscription et aux robes est atteint
comme mon choix se porte sur philippe
edmond-mariette pour deux raisons
d'abord parce qu'elle a vu des débats je
les trouvais bien plus compétents et
maîtrise son sujet et moi c'est ce que
je veux je veux envoyer à l'assemblée
nationale des martiniquais qui soit
capable de porter une voix ferme mais
surtout une voix qui est lucide sur les
problématiques que nous connaissons dans
le cas de joseph ma main du conseil gel
a été beaucoup aidé par david zobda et
elle doit s'en féliciter mais elle
laisse aussi derrière la vôtre
oui la vie tu sais pas ce que vous savez
que je suis une femme de vérité que je
vous plais pas la langue de bois madame
anne un parti en laissant beaucoup de
difficultés après elle a même refusé de
faire le bilan de son action au moment
de la sélection de 2015 donc je ne dis
pas je sais factuel c'est factuel et
c'est pour ça que mon choix ne se porte
pas sur elle de surcroît comme je vous
l'aï dit tout à l'heure
elle a clairement dit qu'elle va siéger
dans l'opposition au président de la
république donc il ya deux bonnes
raisons pour lesquelles je ne peux pas
demander aux électeurs et aux électrices
du rouble qui me suivent qui
m'apprécient et qui me demande de
continuer à m'investir pour eux de
madame manet moi je dis très sincèrement
mes électeurs qu'ils sont libres mais en
même temps je leur dis que mon âme et
conscience le meilleur choix c'est celui
de monsieur edmond mari même s'il semble
se rapprocher de plus en plus du
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
ce n'est pas vrai du tout alors
justement ce soutien à philippe
edmond-mariette cacherait je dis bien
lorsqu'on suit des échanges sur les
réseaux sociaux
ce soutien à philippe edmond-mariette
cacherait déjà des enjeux municipaux
pour 2020 pour vous robert parce que
affaiblir josette manin sosa aussi
affaiblir son suppliant un certain
giovanni williams et son sous cliente
on parle de lui surtout comme étant un
jeune qui monte de plus en plus alors
première question est ce que c'est sa
façon de stratégie de chanteurs mignon
ce serait assez étonnant parce que le
suppléant finalement la suppléante de
monsieur edmond mariette est justement
madame colère qui dans l'équipe de la
majorité municipale ça veut dire que je
renforce fait mon dieu c'est incohérent
ça n'a aucun sens si et votre bon score
au robert samedi dernier ces bons
chiffres ont t'ils ressusciter une
vocation municipal pour vous d'ailleurs
ont-elles disparu ces vocations ainsi
pas pour le robert elle n'a jamais
disparu puisque les verts brillait les
robes étaient me demande en permanence
de continuer à m'investir
mais par contre je réponds permanence
que c'est pas une personne qui fait une
élection municipale c'est une équipe et
causé un certain moment il faut par une
relève et que cette relève elle doit se
construire sous de la loyauté sur le
respect de la parole donnée
peut-être le supplie madame manet à
tréguier de la parole ce sont les
politiques
je pense que pour la jeune génération
devrait faire sienne justement cette
maxime et ses valeurs et je pense que le
suppléant de madame manet à les oublier
puisqu'il est parti au ppm à l'insu de
son groupe en apportant quand même de
manda
sans doute la dignité serait de
démissionner et de recommencer justement
sa petite construction politique dans le
courage comme je lé fais le prm va-t-il
encore exister ou vous destinez vous a
structuré la république en marche ici en
martinique alors c'est une très bonne
question parce que il faudra réfléchir à
cela est ce que le temps de la
balkanisation des petits partis comme
une houe n'est pas à terminer
est ce qu'il nous faudra pas justement
nous rassembler dans quelque chose de
plus vaste
est ce que nous décidons de rester
toujours on mange de la république ne
pas travailler avec le président ça n'a
jamais été moi mon intention je pense
que ce serait une très bonne chose de
structuré une fédération autonome de en
marche
voilà puisque la partie va se construire
molesté n'existe pas il ya un gros
regret qu'il craignait la concurrence
sera accrue mathieu gama au départ
ensuite eric coop est aujourd'hui daniel
robin justin pamphile retenu au second
tour de laisser passer l'occasion d'être
aiguillé belle concurrence de son essor
souches peuvent prétendre à ce poste de
chef de file des marchands martini a
aucun problème ils ont qu'à la prendre
il n'y a aucun problème
le parti ne soit pas seulement 6 d'entre
eux oui mais c'est normal
la tension etc personnellement je suis
plus la pacification peu parti se
structure avec bien évidemment
indifférent mais surtout avec un comité
de direction il y a quand même
énormément de choses à faire dans la
structuration de partie il faut être
nombreux et toutes ces personnes de
qualité sont les bienvenus j'apporterai
ma pierre à l'édifice
mais je n'ai aucunement la velléité de
vouloir en être le chef vous voyez
chantal maignan se souvient de quelques
discussions que nous avons eues ici dans
ce sud doit ce micro dans cette émission
la politique et chantal maignan ça ne
pouvait pas durer que dix ans comme vous
l'aviez annoncé madame mignon écoutez
j'avais quand même réfléchir nous sommes
en 2017 nous avons encore quelques mois
nous sommes au mois de juin je vais
quand même réfléchir parce que vous
savez il n'ya qu'une seule vie et
malheureusement nous venons de perdre
quelqu'un qui est très connu et qui
était quelqu'un que je respectais
beaucoup voyez 68 ans mais c'est très
peu donc la politique c'est très
important mais il faut faire de la
politique si vous sentez que vous avez
aussi l'approbation de votre population
si les robertins élevé après rien ne me
donne pas leur confiance ce samedi je
saurai ce que j'ai à faire
merci beaucoup chantent un mineur
président du parti régionaliste
martiniquais merci d'avoir été ce matin
dans son crédit bonne journée
[Musique]